what you hit way this is a low signal
season Don asensio is proud of his
collection of pan pipes in the town of
San Miguel in the eastern lowland of
Bolivia pan pipes are traditionally
played in church on festive occasions
but the custom is dying out fewer and
fewer young Bolivians are learning to
play the liturgical music German
missionary 17 part singer is trying to
stem that tide with his sound recorder
pencil and paper he's doing all he can
to help the cheeky tonnos preserve their
musical tradition
[Music]
San Miguel is in Bolivia's sparsely
populated chiquito region and has just
400 residents tourists seldom venture
into this area of the country even
though it's part of a UNESCO World
Heritage Site
[Music]
in the seventeenth and eighteenth
centuries the Jesuits established
several of their world-renowned missions
here to protect the indigenous peoples
from exploitation and enslavement by the
Spanish colonists they settled the
Chiquita nose in villages called
reductions these flourished as cultural
centers but the dignity and respect with
which the missionaries treated the
native peoples inflamed the slave
traders and in 1776 the Jesuits were
expelled their settlements disbanded
[Music]
he don't mean it died last okay don't
when the Jesuits left the musical
tradition they had fostered also began
to fade Don Esteban is one of the few
chiquita knows who can still play the
old songs the 80 year old violinist used
to perform at all the special occasions
in San Miguel brother séverine often
visits Don Esteban and his wife the
elderly gentleman is an invaluable
source of knowledge about the chiquita
knows musical heritage easy palestina
these traditional musicians and there
are only a few of these old guys left
are custodians of an oral tradition I
know that's one one or two of the most
key of them died a whole universe of
knowledge about traditional music and
musical compositions will die with them
and I'm trying to prevent that from
happening I can't just stand by and
watch everything disappear in without
his for doing it Don Esteban takes
brother séverine to the chapel where he
keeps his violin at home he says it
would not be safe from rats Don Esteban
never plays simply to entertain for him
music has a sacred purpose his
repertoire consists holy of liturgical
music brother sevrin has recorded some
70 melodies in this way today he has
asked Don Esteban to play one about the
exultation of the cross
it is yet another piece composed during
the Jesuit era when the missionaries
were expelled from Bolivia their
parishioners were left to fend for
themselves nearly a hundred years passed
before priests were allowed to return in
the meantime the native population
maintained their tradition of religious
processions and the old music don
esteban knows many of the melodies when
brother sevrin returns home he transfers
the recordings to his music archives
[Music]
to become even more familiar with the
melodies he plays them himself on his
own violin
[Music]
in the days leading up to Easter san
miguel is a hive of activity a heavy
figure of christ is removed from the
cross to be paraded in the streets this
is not just a theatrical spectacle to
the faithful they are devoutly following
Christ on the final journey to his place
of execution in various processions they
accompany their Jesus through the
village the events are organized by the
Cabildo a council of elders
traditionally responsible for
coordinating the major religious events
brother 17 lends a hand the young German
is a member of the Catholic divine word
missionary congregation and lives in the
priests house in San Miguel the parish
priest is also a divine word missionary
cigars a 4-bedroom sanofi all these
preparations are definitely a spiritual
exercise the people experience them as
an act of faith you stayed in the very
small details the way somebody bowels in
front of the Cross or kisses the cross
where the nails that will bore through
Christ's hands and feet are not just
placed on the table but on a little
cushion as a sign of veneration of extra
populated visits not just done casually
highly had when dr. Smith ever saw my
leave by
the evening of Maundy Thursday
commemoration of the Last Supper the
village elders enter the church
accompanied by a group of musicians Don
asencio is among them after the mass
these flautists and drummers will also
accompany the procession through the
village brother 17 has already recorded
their music this evening he wants to
document its relationship to the
ceremonies
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sessional the moment I became a I
realized very quickly that you can't
understand the message of the music you
can't see it in the context until you
understand the traditions the
processions anybody misses when's what
is happening and how the main celebrant
this evening is Father Miguel the
provincial superior of the Divine Word
missionaries who serve a number of
parishes in this unspoiled region of
Bolivia between santa cruz and the
Brazilian border
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
brother Severin's love of music is
evident during the service he learned to
play the violin and the piano when he
was a schoolboy and the violin is partly
responsible for his posting to Bolivia
[Music]
when severing pot singer graduated from
high school he volunteered for community
service with the divine word
missionaries abroad a music school in
Bolivia was looking for a violinist part
singer applied and was accepted
[Music]
when he arrived in San Miguel he
discovered that the young people were no
longer interested in the church music
played by their fathers and grandfathers
the tradition had survived for
generations now its continuation seemed
unlikely severine decided to do
something about that people saw me with
my sound recorder in the music school
and I fell into conversation with some
of the musicians I said to them now it's
only you old people well I didn't put it
quite like that but that's what I meant
and they said yes we're old and there
are always fewer of us what is often
Dean if India but it's obvious that they
long for the tradition to be passed on
vinegar nobody ssed scenes with fastest
way to get is done on monday thursday
members of the Cabildo shoulder the
cross raised on a wood platform meant to
represent Calvary Hill
the cross is carried through the streets
together with the figure of the grieving
mother Mary
[Music]
empress eve sinned against in all these
processions and the statues that are
carried are basically a legacy of the
Jesuits the change hasn't been broken in
300 years like me up catism as yang if I
can happen oven when I began recording I
thought I would just do a few and be
done with it and then I realized it
wasn't that simple at the very least you
have to describe the processions and all
the traditional elements as well
otherwise you can understand the music
15 brother 17 doesn't just archive the
recordings he also transcribes them he
now has a whole book full of songs
let's meet them it helps me to find the
pieces more quickly in to compare
melodies sometimes for instance I see
that some parts appear in more than one
composition like
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
austin de vaina this is for Easter this
is for Christmas this is for the village
festival this is for blessing food these
are pieces that are played throughout
the year this is of the exultation of
the Cross High to get price there's a
song to venerate st. Joseph's fit in
highly can yo safe and here's another
one for Easter I said this is fear
Austin
[Music]
without a motorcycle it would take
brother 17 hours to reach one of the
small villages belonging to the parish
he's on the move again gathering
material for his music archives I run
from one person to the next someone
knows somebody who plays the panpipes so
I pay him a visit and we get to talking
hyc can evoke must buses fabric and I
ask him if he's prepared to help me if
he's prepared to make a contribution of
meets a vehicle on sending tibetans
bites of the dang it goes it yeah on
hell is one of the youngest musicians he
taught himself how to play the melodies
which is unusual even though it's only
for a recording on hell insists on
wearing the appropriate attire it
includes a mirror attached to his shirt
which is meant to scare off demons
brother 17 is very respectful of the
indigenous peoples traditions that's the
reason he was able to win the musicians
trust
[Music]
feed him undermine skipped ish many were
skeptical at first what's this white guy
doing recording everything so did you
see I thought on this I was get by that
badness oskins the experience of being
exploited is deeply ingrained in these
people on many different levels well
definitely afraid of being exploited
they were apprehensive and and you have
to respect that most buddies all how to
speak to you now see I can only go as
far as the people are willing to share
their legacy with me yet been with me
it's a time how would I love roses yo
hey initially 7-passenger came to
Bolivia to do community service and
stayed nearly two years but he couldn't
have imagined where that would lead the
work of the missionaries in Bolivia
impressed him so deeply that he decided
to join the Divine Word congregation
when he returned to Germany while still
a theology student he told his superiors
about his music project in Bolivia and
they encouraged him to continue it since
the missionaries training included some
field experience they sent him back to
San Miguel
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the
as it for me he's this is completely in
the spirit of missionary work in
medicine firstly it demonstrates an
interest in the local culture in which
i'm living and working the attempt to
understand this culture is the basis of
all of our work 15 supposition is the
basis for either Albert yeah
good friday the evening procession is
preceded by a kind of passion play
portraying the events leading up to the
crucifixion of Jesus the men and women
become deeply involved in the suffering
and death of Christ
religious ceremonies here are strongly
influenced by popular piety when the
body of the crucified Lord is laid in
the tomb for instance Jesus is crowned
with a triple tiara the Pope's
traditional head where we can only guess
where this comes from presumably there
was once a statue of Saint Peter here
crowned with the papal tiara since he
was believed to be the first pope the
statue itself seems to have disappeared
only the precious tiara remains and who
in the minds of the people could be more
worthy to wear this crown than Christ so
when the body of Christ is taken down
from the cross it's now crowned with the
papal tiara
brother 17 has already recorded the
melodies that are played during the
procession now he has only to document
their place in the ceremony I was until
he shall not have maybe the end of
Santa's meeting of course it's always
interesting to hear the music being
played during the procession itself not
just being practiced at home is that how
it sounds when the altar boys are
ringing the little bells and when the
big church bells tolled as the prayers
are said to capture the music in its
true context given identifying the more
brother severine immersed himself in the
religious traditions of this region the
more he realized that the language of
the cheeky da nose is one of the keys to
understanding them so he decided to
learn it an afternoon with Donna a
ballina she is teaching brother séverine
and language that fewer and fewer locals
still speak the young missionary is used
to his teacher weaving a hammock during
his lessons it's her main source of
income
[Music]
fish fish no my max under stillati style
it's very messy like you can see that
people feel proud when somebody shows an
interest in their language and culture I
got enough in the past it was always
denigrated it was even taboo to speak
Chiquita no it wasn't accepted she was
actively discouraged in the school's
children who spoke dialect were punished
side they had to speak Spanish let's now
change somebody comes along who wants to
learn the language that sends out a
message yes it's your identity it's
valuable not something you should
discard ignore or forget a visit to Don
ascencio like many of his fellow
musicians he lives in very modest
surroundings his room doesn't even have
a proper floor these days people are
delighted when brother séverine turns up
with his sound recorder they trust him
special I'm gonna solo does things at
first musicians only confided part of
their knowledge to me so that I could
make some recordings they withheld some
key pieces of music as I so ipod they
were afraid that once I had it all
they'd no longer be needed they would
lose their authority their role in the
community then they were afraid of being
replaced by audio tape Medicare
classical stone by the system
[Music]
yeah mid-level a shady people started to
appreciate what I'm doing here they
understand my intentions PNC's wouldn't
I say to me we forgot to record that
we've still got to do that you can see
that they're suddenly proud of what they
can share with me was self-deceit titan
commitment when he started this work
brother 17 encountered a particular
issue that was already familiar to him
from his native Germany you like the I'm
give mind us at them when the musicians
claim that they need to drink alcohol or
they wouldn't be able to play with the
fact that musicians tend to drink a lot
I saw it back in Bavaria by yeah the
brass bands can't play unless you give
them a beer and it's more or less the
same here oh oh that gives that off work
does it yeah I'm your Yaya's kid don't
be all right Don asensio doesn't only
have a collection of musical instruments
he also safeguards the masks worn at
Easter yo te amo ESO tiene su phu
cheerio burrito ESO es que no get easy
to Sinatra everything is done according
to customers collective get xmas
thousand these are just oral traditions
but they're firmly embedded in the
collective memory and that's my starting
point if I want to work with the culture
especially with these religious
traditions I have to share in the lives
of the people have to listen to their
stories
brother separating lives in the priests
house father Dennis from Papua New
Guinea is the current pastor the
provincial superior Father Miguel who
has always supported Severin's music
project is currently visiting being part
of the pastoral team helps facilitate
brother severance contact with the
parishioners
[Music]
the Paschal candle symbol of the
resurrection brother séverine also sings
in the church up in the 350s can't or I
have a different status I'm the pastor's
deputy a person they respect
[Music]
after the easter procession brother
severing slips back into the role of the
observer he takes his camera and
documents a strange easter procession
it's a race between the risen Christ and
his mother Mary or more precisely
between the two groups carrying their
statues the women carry Mary and the men
carried Jesus
and even though the men are faster this
time they show deference to the mother
of god the two statues are reunited and
the happy throng returns to the church
[Music]
on Easter Sunday morning there's another
unusual custom the head of the Cabildo
delivers a speech in chiquita no at the
church doors his sermon is an
explanation of the message of Easter
that is handed down from generation to
generation brother seven records it for
posterity okay hippo give even felicity
I definitely have the impression that
people are changing as a result of my
interest in their language and their
traditional rites and their music it
increases their sense of self-worth they
feel proud when they can present
elements of their culture even so you
quit ahead on Easter Sunday the music
becomes more joyous and cheerful
unfortunately there are no violinists
this year but donis ncos masks are put
to good effect they represent the
murderers of Jesus who are now ashamed
of their actions and hide their faces
[Music]
then the musicians parade through the
village playing the pan pipes and drums
at the same time demands a lot of skill
but Don asensio is no longer afraid that
the centuries-old traditions will die
out Metheny kisses and even super common
its own the aim of this documentation
this cultural project is of course to
build a bridge and to make the material
available in 10 years someone says we
miss it it was so beautiful but the man
who played it has died we can't dig him
up but we'd like to resurrect the
traditions miss Goodin beginning then
all the material that I've collected
will be there as a deaf ear if my dad to
humans of shame
[Music]
there's a party at the parish center
it's a way of thanking all those who
played a role in the commemoration of
the death and resurrection of Christ
brother sevrin is here to his work
carries the hope that a tradition that
has shaped son began for 300 years will
continue when Miss Agnes musica stop it
said all of a sudden they're saying it
can't disappear it's our identity our
culture our roots we can't deny
ourselves that the aim of my work is to
support them as their awareness grows an
interesting
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I